Năm 2, 2,5 gỷ dấu móc là đầu tiên số thu ngân sách dó ngành tối khoản lý
vượt 2,2 triệu tỷ đồng.
Tuy nhiên, tình trạng lợt tối vẫn gia tăng với hơn 50 gỷ dấu giống trường hợp
bị áp dụng bệnh pháp tảng hoàn sức cạnh, gió trây ý ý vụ tối.
Bộ tại chính cho biết, tổng thu ngân sách dó ngành tối khoản lý
đặt hơn 2,2 triệu tỷ đồng, vượt dự tỏng năm 2,5 gỷ dấu.
Và tăng 2,5 gỷ dấu.
Đây là năm đầu tiên ngành tối đặt bức tu này.
Dạy đoạn 2 gàn khu học trầm hay mốt 2 gàn khu học trầm hay lăm
tổng thu gió ngành tối khoản lý đặt khoản tảng phải 1,2 triệu tỷ đồng
chỉ hơn 3 xo hơn trầm tổng thu ngân sách nhả nước.
Năm 2 gàn khu học trầm hay lăm, tổng bộ 3,5 gỷ dấu hoàn thành dự tỏng thu
trong đó, hà nội thu xấu trầm 3,5 gỷ dấu.
Thành phố hộ chỉ mình là xấu trầm lình xấu nhìn tỷ đồng.
Cơ cấu thu ngân sách tiếp tục chuyển dịch theo hướng mệnh vướng với tỷ trọng thu lợi điện tăng lên 3 xấu
về xấu phần trầm.
Tuy nhiên, lợi thuế đến cuối năm, ước khoảng 2,5 gàn chính trầm 2,5 gỷ dồng
tăng mười 2,5 gỷ dấu phần trầm xấu với năm trước.
Gàn thuế đã bán hành hơn chỉ mối mốt ngàn xấu trầm thương bảo tảng khoản xuất cạnh.
Quà đó, thu hồi trên xấu miền một tỷ đồng điện lợi thuế.